[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Let me get started
by asking if there are any
questions from last time.
You know I really
like questions.
AUDIENCE: So just to be
clear, I do have a question.
So just to be clear,
for the pollution
stuff for the last time, there
are a bazillion prices, right?
There's not just one price.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: There
was one price for permits.
The model is simple.
So there's only one
dimension of pollution.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We kind of
did it as a partial equilibrium
problem.
So the consumers
would take a price
as given and deciding
how many permits to sell.
The single firm in that example
would take prices as given
and decide how much to produce.
But in the equilibrium,
there would
be a common price for permits.
AUDIENCE: OK.
In that case, I'm a bit
confused about something.
If you have permits and stuff,
if you have 1,000 people,
if you have one person
selling a permit,
if that person sells a
permit to have more pollution
be polluted, then that pollution
gets spread out over everyone.
So the price that someone
would be willing to sell
would be much lower
than the actual price
that person carried out
pollution or something.
Or am I thinking about it wrong?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No, no, no.
You're absolutely right.
So that part is
missing from the model
because we only had one consumer
or we talked about the consumer
as a representative consumer
and everybody wanting
to do the same thing.
But you're right, there
could be a potential conflict
of interest if you're
all supposed to pay--
well, there's something called
the Lindahl equilibrium that
was just going to take us to
far off the path of the lecture
that actually elicits
from each household
their willingness
to pay for pollution
and then adds up
those numbers to get
the sum of the
willingness to pay.
And then, that number
is, quote, "compared"
to what the firms are willing
to pay for the input costs.
So that's the way the
generalization would go.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
It's a good question.
Other questions.
So just to remind you all,
this is the last lecture 21,
the last lecture I'm giving,
although I will have class
on Tuesday, which is another
review session focusing mainly
on the material that we've
covered since the last time,
trying as I usually do
in those review sessions,
to bring the pieces together.
So that's the class schedule.
Then, for the reading list
today, for the lecture
today, there are these
two starred papers.
And one is this Abel, Mankiw,
Summers, Zeckhauser paper
and how it's like one or two
slides in the lecture today.
We didn't spend a lot of
time on it in the lecture,
but it's listed there as
a supplemental reading,
along with my own paper.
I'll spend a little more
time on my own paper.
Anyway, I'm kind of treating
you guys as you are,
as fully functioning economists.
So you should be able to
read the Abel, et al, paper
and understand it without me
going over it this lecture.
And the previous one
had that style to it.
In fact, last time was
the first time, I think,
that I didn't finish
the lecture material
and asked you nevertheless
to go ahead and understand
the lecture and to read
the starred reading.
So I did not do this too,
too much at the beginning
of the course.
But now that you're
truly trained,
I think you're more independent.
Anyway, feel free to ask
me questions about those
at any time,
including next time,
if it comes up
because it's material
that we really haven't
covered much in the lectures
but I started.
So meaning, I do expect
you to understand it.
And then, for the
review sheets, we
were doing the failures
of the welfare theorems.
The way these review
questions are written,
they're largely review.
It's kind of like telling
you what you need to know.
It's hard to ask you
when the answer is given,
but I'll give it a try anyway.
It says, you should know
well the formal statement
of the first welfare
theorem and conditions
under which it holds.
So again, I think I'll
just take volunteers.
Can someone tell me the
roughly or even more
carefully the statement of
the first welfare theorem?
OK.
There are two welfare theorems.
AUDIENCE: OK.
If I remember correctly,
the first welfare theorem
is something like assuming
local nonsatiation
and I don't think
it's convexity,
but there's second
conditions that I forget.
But to mean, local nonsatiation
and something else.
Then, the practical Walrasian,
like, price equilibrium
is pretty optimal.
If I remember right.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
That's right.
It was local nonsatiation and
a statement about rationality
of consumer preferences.
So very, very weak,
which is probably
why they're hard to remember.
Yeah.
But the local
nonsatiation is there.
And then, the pollution we've
already started talking about.
Pollution permits.
Why did we need those
permits in the first place?
What was it that we did wrong?
Since the first welfare
theorem is supposed to hold
and even assuming
local nonsatiation,
what why did it fail in the end?
AUDIENCE: Is it really like
a market for pollution?
So like, people's preferences
don't get accounted for there.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yep.
Exactly.
So it's a missing
market problem.
We assume their L goods and
their markets in all of them
when we do the proof of
the first welfare theorem.
In this case, we
kind of left one out.
So there aren't
prices there to guide
the solution of the market
to the situation where
the marginal rates of
substitution over households
are equated to the marginal
rate of production across firms.
So that that's the
nature of the problem.
And likewise, I thought
I indicated one other.
What about the second
welfare theorem?
Can anyone state it, including
some of the assumptions that
are needed?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I can take a stab at this one.
So the second
welfare theorem says
that basically any optimal
point is supported by some while
raising equilibrium
up to transfers.
And some assumptions that
we need for that are we
need convex open
consumption sets.
We need convex closed
production sets
with this concave
transformation function.
We need concave and locally
nonsatiated preferences.
And I think the last
one is basically
just like a budget constraint
in some sort basically.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
It's some interiority condition.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
That's right.
So yeah, so this one takes a bit
more in terms of assumptions.
And then, I showed
in the lecture
two pictures of
illustrative examples
of where things could go wrong.
One had nonconvexity
in the preferences,
and the other had
nonconvexity in production.
I don't know if it helps
to give the math intuition.
When we did the second
welfare theorem,
we were kind of getting those
shadow prices by solving
the Pareto problem and
then essentially using them
as candidates for the
Walrasian or equilibrium
or the equilibrium
with transfers.
And those shadow prices
are marginal conditions.
They are derivatives
having to do
with differentiating the
Lagrangian with respect
to constraints.
Another way to put that is
the candidate for prices
are essentially
margin utilities.
Weighted margin utilities, at
least in the Pareto problem,
would be equated to a
common Lagrange multiplier.
And that's what I meant by
marginal utility pricing,
that the Lagrange multiplier
becomes the price.
It's kind of amazing because
it's all teeny tiny local.
Once we find the candidate
we want, all we need to do
is look at the derivatives
for very small movements
around that point and then
kind of separate the problem
globally.
So it's not just
that at those prices,
households and firms are max--
I mean, that's true, but
they're not only just
maximizing locally, they
could, in principle,
choose things that are very far
away from that local point that
are global.
And that was the point
of those two figures
with the nonconvexity
in preferences
or, alternatively,
nonconvexity in production,
you could see how
locally things look fine.
But if you drift
pretty far away,
you find another
point that either
maximizes profits or
maximizing utility,
depending on the example.
So all of this
stuff we're learning
was kind of worked out
by British economists
and then formalized
by Paul Samuelson.
It's called the sort
of marginal analysis
way of doing economics.
So that's good.
So that that's
essentially all I want
to do in terms of
reviewing from last class.
Well, the other
thing-- yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
When I mentioned the
first welfare theorem,
we just assumed that
the preference are
original and the nonsatiation.
And we say that the
production is a nonempty.
And we don't consider whether
the production function
is convex or not.
But I notice that if the
production function is
nonconvex, we see
there might not have
any competitive equilibrium.
For example, when the
production function is now
convex, then the--
yeah, then the slide 3 showed
that the point which consumers
want to be maximizing utility.
But at this point, it
was not at the producers
to maximize their profits.
So in this situation, can we
say that was at equilibrium?
It looks like there was no
equilibrium in this situation.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
It's a good question.
And it gives me an
opportunity to clarify.
There are two theorems.
One, if a competitive
equilibrium exists,
and it's optimal, that's
the first welfare theorem.
That's the one that only
needs local nonsatiation
and rationality.
And the reason-- and it's
true, when there's production,
and there are no assumptions
about production,
but the intuition
for why it works
is you're given so much
information already,
namely this competitive
equilibrium exists.
So what's ever going on,
firms were maximizing profits,
and that added up
to demand and so on.
So all that stuff is
kind of implicitly given
in the statement of the
problem, if the conditionality,
if a competitive equilibrium
exists, then something else
is true.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I get it.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then, I slipped
up too when I
was going through those
examples because I'd
forgotten that I'd switched
to the second welfare theorem.
So the second welfare
theorem is the starting point
is Pareto optimal.
And I should have, when I
went over those figures,
emphasized how it was
the single-best point
in the whole space and could not
be Pareto dominated, and then
settled into the second
part of the second welfare
theorem, which is
then you can maybe not
decentralize if you
lose the convexity.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
I'm glad.
I like questions.
I know it's the last class.
By the way, please come ready
to ask questions next time.
That's a much more
fun way to review
what we've done in the
course than it is for me
to lecture all over again.
All right.
That said, I should lecture
all over again, I guess.
Here's lecture 21.
And again, without exaggerating,
this one, like the last one,
is kind of exciting, both for
the topics that are covered
and because it's building
on material that you now
know that was spread out
throughout the course.
I suppose a better
title for this one
would have been monetary
economics or cryptocurrency.
But Bubbles is a
more appealing title.
And as you will see,
bubbles can exist,
meaning something has
value that has no value.
And they can be optimal.
And that also creates a
scope for monetary policy.
So these things look really
different from the welfare
theorems that we just did.
And essentially, the
reason that it's happening
is either that we have a
version of incomplete markets
or we have an infinite
number of commodities.
But rather than
reiterating those theorems,
so this is the monetary
economic slide.
Let me tell you in words how
we can get fiat money to have
value, even when it's worth
much more than the paper it's
printed on.
So you have these
kinds of agents
moving in opposite directions.
Some are moving west,
as in the top line.
Others are moving east,
as in the bottom line.
And every period, they hit
one of these trading posts.
So the sequence experienced
by the people traveling west,
if they start with one,
then next period they're
going to have 0 goods,
that's their endowment.
Then one good and so on.
And the guys going in
the opposite direction
have the opposite sequence.
Whenever they're able to trade
at these vertical lines, which
are trading posts, one agent
has one and the other has 0.
And then, the basic
idea is somehow
the guy with 0 goods also
has these pieces of paper
called fiat money.
And they give them up.
They have value, and they get
one sum amount of the good
from the person who
has the real commodity.
So there's a trade going
on between goods and money.
So we have to extend the
commodity space to include
these pieces of paper.
And then, the guy
that basically got
the money is willing to
take it because he or she is
about to experience in the
next period 0 real endowment.
But they can spend the money
to a person with one who
was in turn willing to take it.
I'll show you this model
at the end of class.
And we'll work some things out.
But that's an example of
an economy with endowments
and preferences that is pretty
awful if there's no money.
But it's much better with it.
And then, yeah,
at the end, we'll
even talk about
optimal monetary policy
in that setup of why
the Fed should be
controlling the interest rate.
This is a similar model down
here, if you can see it.
You have people going one
direction or the other.
When they meet, though, they
stay together for two periods.
So this person's
endowment goes a
in the first period, 0
endowment of the good
in the second period.
The opposite is true.
This one has 0 and then B.
So over these two periods,
they can borrow and lend
from each other.
So this is just like a snapshot
of a two-period intertemporal
economy with
borrowing and lending,
which they will want
to do because they
have extreme endowment
positions of the real good.
But it doesn't end there.
After they're paired like
that, one goes to the east,
the other goes to the west.
And if you think like a
is a very, very big number
and b is a very small
number, this economy
starts to look like
the one above it,
where they're going
from large number
to something almost 0, large
number to something almost 0.
And the person below going
in the other direction
has the opposite pattern.
So this economy displays
both real credit,
borrowing and lending and
real goods, and fiat money.
And of course, in the economy we
live in, we arguably have both.
We have fiat money,
and we have borrowing
and lending and credit markets.
And then, finally, we go
to this third economy,
where there are two locations.
Agent 1 is always residing
in the first location.
Agent 2 is always
residing in the--
Agent 4, I'm sorry, is residing
in the second location.
And these other two agents
labeled 2 and 3 switch
locations.
2 goes from 1 to 2, then
back to 1, et cetera.
And 3 has the opposite pattern.
You can kind of create this by
taking this so-called turnpike
and bending it around so that
it meets like a merry-go-round.
And that would create something
very similar to this economy.
So much more fun, you
can see at date 1 and 3,
Agents 1 and 2 are
paired with each other.
So you can imagine that
borrowing and lending,
simple two-period
loans, are possible.
And depending on endowments
and preferences, desirable.
So we have short-term
credit, two-period debt,
but also watch this.
Now say 1 issues an
IOU to 2, a promise
to pay in the fourth period.
2 travels and passes it along
to 4, 4 passes it along the 3,
and 3 passes it
along to 1, who was
the initial issuer of the IOU.
And there are several
other network chains
like that in this economy.
And those would be debt.
They're private IOUs.
They're not fiat money.
But they would facilitate
exchange and act
like privately issued monies.
Now, you do have to redeem
your force in the model
to pay back the loan
in the fourth period.
But meanwhile, those IOUs
circulate in the population.
So this is a real
economy, no fiat money.
But there is a kind of money
circulating private debt
with high velocity.
That IOU passes hands
every single period.
It has the highest single
velocity in the whole economy.
Velocity is the amount
traded per unit time divided
by the stock.
Another implicit thing
going on in this comparison
is, depending how often
agents meet with one another,
you could evolve from
a monetary economy
with valued fiat
money to the point
that the credit markets get so
good, especially with privately
issued debt, that you don't
need fiat money at all.
So don't tell the
Federal Reserve.
They're not going to
be happy about it.
But that tension is there.
And I think part of the
issue with digital assets
and cryptocurrency is that it's
kind of filling in the market
and can lead us to a
situation where the fiat
money is no longer valued.
Well, I mean, you get the
same thing in this model.
a meets b for two periods, then
three periods, then n periods.
So they're together so
much, the residual gap
is not enough to create
valued fiat money.
So these slides then
go back to the issue
of either monetary policy
or distributed ledgers.
We talked about distributed
ledgers throughout the class
off and on.
Maybe that wasn't effective
because it pops up
in different spots,
depending on the lecture.
But if you look at
1 passes it to 2,
2 passes it to 4,
to 3, and back to 1,
there's another path over
here where 3 issues it to 4,
4 gives it to 2, 2 gives it to
1, and 1 passes it back to 3.
It turns out that you
don't need both of them.
But if the amount of
short-term circulating debt
is not coordinated, then
you can run into troubles.
Another way to say that is
there are multiple equilibria,
a continuum of
equilibria, but you
need to coordinate on the
amount of the privately
issued currencies that are about
to circulate in the economy.
And if these are informationally
decentralized locations,
if they're not
supposed to know what's
going on in the other
location, then there's
no way they can coordinate.
So one of the advantages
of distributed ledgers
would be, especially if you
write smart contracts on them,
that you can solve this
coordination problem.
And I think that's where we're
going with digital assets,
except people aren't
thinking about it yet.
We're going to end up
with financial crises,
not because digital
assets are bad,
but because there's a
coordination problem.
Fortunately, we have a
solution in the ledgers.
It's not crazy to link
this to central banks
because I mentioned
once to you IOUs that
circulated in Medieval England.
Those were those willow sticks.
Eventually, they
were issuing pieces
of paper, promissory notes as
IOUs, that were circulating
in the population.
And in London, those
bills of exchange were--
well, all of England and
especially in London,
there were markets
for those bills.
But occasionally,
they would crash.
And so that's actually
what gave rise
to one of the first
central banks in the world,
the Central Bank
of England, where
it would buy up those bills
that were falling in price.
That's the way
monetary policy used
to work when the
Fed buys treasuries.
But they may have created
the wrong institution
because the problem likely was
the coordination problem, not
the fact that the private
markets were intrinsically
flawed.
And the other aspect that
we're going to cover today
is that fiat money
can be introduced.
Even though it's
worth nothing, it's
going to have a positive value.
And that's going to
create other problems.
It's not like it's
totally stable.
It could be moving
around, which brings us
to the other kind
of money, Bitcoin,
which was introduced
to be a money
and to replace fiat money.
That's what really made
the central bank so annoyed
with the whole
Nakamoto experiment.
They were threatened by Bitcoin.
So a bit historical here.
I kept it in for a reason.
When I first started teaching,
I grabbed this slide,
which has to do with
the price of Bitcoin
moving from $100
to $147 in 2013.
People were already talking
about how ridiculous that was.
And it wasn't tied to anything.
So the value was
completely indeterminate.
But remember, fiat
money is just like that.
When you have the head
of the Federal Reserve
Bank of New York, Dudley,
saying the problem with Bitcoin
is that it has no
fundamental value,
don't throw stones if
you live in glass houses
because fiat money
has the same problem.
And it's just that
in the US, fiat money
is respected and not unstable.
Anyway, back to
the $100 to $147,
I can't see your
faces very well,
but you may be a bit puzzled
because if you looked at what
the value is now, it's $19,372.
So over here, at the low
end, the price was so low,
it looks like it's 0 now
when we change the scale.
And then, of course,
it jumped up in '17,
I guess it was, and
hit about $19,000.
And this is the most recent--
I kind of did this because
I told you I was aware
of the price three days ago
was the highest on record.
As of yesterday, it's
back down about $200
below the highest point.
But essentially, these are
almost identical spikes.
Where do you think
it's going to go?
You want to buy?
Well, what determines
the value of this stuff?
OK.
So maybe only that
it's used in exchange.
Would that pin down the value?
The answer is no.
And now you're going
to see the model.
So this is the overlapping
generations model.
I mentioned last time we have an
infinity of goods and infinity
of households.
Nobody lives forever.
But there's one
generation after another.
We saw last time
a version of that,
that we could have a
competitive equilibrium where
the price of the second
good was 1, everyone
had 2 units of wealth, and they
could all end up in autarky.
And there was a way
to Pareto dominate
the competitive equilibrium.
So that is true here in
this is more general setup.
A little bit of a
better-known setup
because this is
Samuelson's model, which
he created at MIT, by the way.
You have two-- let's
simplify the lifetime.
You're either young or old.
So no middle-aged people.
No people living 100 years.
They just live two periods.
How many of them?
We're going to put a little
population growth in the model.
So there's an initial
population L0 at date 0.
Then, L1 at date 1
is 1 plus n times L0.
So there's a rate of
population growth of n.
L3 is 1 plus nL which
is 1 plus n squared L1.
So if the initial
population is 1,
then the total population
satisfies this equation.
It'll be interesting
and annoying
because we're going
to have to keep
track of the number of
people all the time.
And we are going to want
to divide by the numbers.
So the algebra
gets to be a pain.
But I'll show you, at least
in one case, how to do it.
And then it will be more clear.
There's only one good period.
But per period, there's an
infinite number of periods.
There's obviously an
infinite number of people,
even though no one lives
more than two periods.
There's a constant return to
scale production technology
that maps the level of the
capital good, real physical
savings, as it were, and
the current labor supply
into output of the single good.
And because it's constant,
returns to scale,
we know that if we multiply
the inputs by a scalar,
the output gets
multiplied by a scalar.
We do the following
trick and let the scalar
be the population itself.
We divide by labor.
So L over L goes to 1, k over
L is now termed little k.
Its capital per capita.
And output would
scale by 1 over L.
And that's like putting
that L over here
on the left-hand side.
We have output per capita.
So we can write basically
a production function
F, which maps output y,
little y, from capital.
So there are two goods here.
There's labor and capital.
They're both used in production.
So the capital stock is brought
in from the previous period
and then used in production.
The marginal product
of capital is
going to be the
rental rate on capital
or it looks like
an interest rate.
And the wage is going to
be the residual of what
isn't paid out in capital.
I could have written down
an explicit expression
for the wage, which would be
the marginal product of labor.
But because we have
constant returns to scale,
we know there are no profits.
And since there are no
profits, the payments
to the factors of production,
labor and capital,
adds up completely to output.
And firms make no profits.
So these are the
expressions for the wage
and for the rental
rate on capital.
But note, that in turn,
because it's a function of k,
It's output less whatever the
marginal return on capital
was times the total amount
of capital involves k,
and k involves r.
So you can write this
as a function of r.
Here's a simple
two-period max problem.
Utility today plus beta
times utility tomorrow.
And how do they do that?
They're endowed with
1 unit of labor today.
They get the wage.
And you can either eat it or
save it, real physical savings,
or call it capital stock.
Likewise tomorrow, they
don't have any income.
They're old.
They're not working.
But they do have that
saving, and the saving
is going to earn interest
at rate little r.
So whatever capital is brought
in to next period, when they're
old, it's going to have
a rate of return of rt
plus 1 for the second period
because they were born at t
in they're old at t plus 1.
So savings times 1
plus the interest rate
would be their consumption.
It kind of looks like Social
Security, except here these
are real physical
savings, the only thing
so far that they're able to do.
No money, no Social
Security, nothing.
So we're going to get a
savings function as a solution
to this problem that's going
to involve the prices, namely
the wage, and the interest rate.
Each household will
take the prices
as given, as we always do in
a competitive equilibrium,
and solve for s.
But that s is, in turn, through
the production function,
going to generate
the interest rate.
And the level of capital
will also determine the wage.
So what is in equilibrium?
If things are going
to add up properly,
then we take the savings
function-- we just
did this-- the savings function
of an individual person at day
t times the number
of persons at day t,
that's the population Lt.
This is total savings,
which is going
to be the total capital stock
used in production tomorrow.
And that's where the
interest rate came from.
It's paid out, supplying a
factor of production tomorrow,
namely that capital.
So this is market clearing.
You might imagine from
Vollrath's law, the only thing
we need to worry about if
we're going to clear savings
equal to the
capital stock, we're
also going to clear the labor
market and everything else.
But let's just focus
on the capital stock.
Now, take this equation here
and divide through by Lt.
Then we have little s on
the right and kt plus 1
over Lt on the left.
That's kind of
weird because we'd
want to normalize by the
actual population in t plus 1,
which is Lt plus 1.
So this will be kt plus 1 over
Lt multiplied by Lt plus 1
over Lt plus 1.
That doesn't change anything.
That's just 1.
But we take that thing in the
denominator, the Lt plus 1,
and stick it under the k,
and that makes it a little k
because that's the per capita
capital stock at t plus 1.
After you did that,
with Lt plus 1 over Lt,
and we know that's already
going up at rate 1 plus n.
So that's where this
first term is coming from.
And I know it's painful
to hear me go over it
verbally because it's
all just algebra.
But this little trick is going
to get used four more times.
So I wanted to draw
your attention to it.
The capital stock
per capita needs
to take into account
the number of people.
The number of capita, so to
speak, is changing over time.
That's kind of the math
of this expression.
Anyway, we have
little s on the right.
And we already know
the wage is a function
of the current capital stock.
The interest rate is a function
of capital stock next period.
Hence, kt and kt plus 1
are in this expression.
So we can effectively
look for what
happens if we start
with initial capital
stock in the whole economy
at date 0, the genesis date,
and stick that capital,
what's going to be in,
solve this equation, what's
going to be the capital
stock tomorrow?
Well, it's meant to
be-- the solution
is meant to be along this
line denoted as this curve.
Looks like a
difference equation,
mapping current
into future capital.
If you start with
current capital,
tomorrow's capital at t plus
1, at 1, would be kt plus 1.
Now you do this trick.
Let's go back and hit the
45-degree line and start over.
Because it's the 45-degree
line, we're putting k1 down here
on the x-axis.
Start at k1, what capital
we have in the third date,
read it off the
s-curve and so on.
And you can see that
it would evolve,
if this line crosses
the 45-degree line,
to a steady state called k star.
So after that, the economy
isn't moving anymore.
There are no more
dates on anything.
It's completely settled down.
So this is a long-run
steady state of the economy,
with only real savings.
Now, let's introduce
pieces of paper that
are intrinsically worthless.
But imagine that
they have value.
And let's denote their
value as the price Pt,
and that is the price of
money in terms of consumption.
It's the opposite of what
you would normally think.
Normally, we think
of consumption
having a dollar price.
This is dollars having
a consumption price.
And I'll keep pointing that out.
So if that consumption price
of money is changing over time,
we put Pt as 1 over Pt,
that would be appreciation.
That's going to be a good thing.
By the way, if it were
a money price, a dollar
price of consumption, then
having the price level go up
would be a bad thing because
it would be depreciating--
it would be inflation.
But here, it's a
good thing because we
flipped the numerator
around to be the opposite.
So this is a rate of return.
This is a real positive rate of
return if Pt plus 1 is over Pt.
And maybe people want to
hold this piece of paper.
If they're going to hold
these pieces of paper,
they have to be indifferent
to that and the other way
to store value over
time, which was namely
physical savings carried over.
They would get the interest
rate, the rental rate on it
next period and get
the savings back.
So if in an equilibrium, there's
both real savings and money,
then this equation has to hold.
We can call the bubble,
the title of the lecture,
the value of money
times its price.
It's in real consumption terms.
So if you just stick Pt plus
1 equals Bt plus 1 over n,
then you can rewrite this
equation too this way
because n is constant.
I'm not manipulating the
amount of money in the economy.
I'm keeping it constant,
although the price is moving.
So then, we have
from 2 this equation
about how the bubble, the
real value of the bubble
is changing over time.
And it's related to the
marginal product of capital.
Furthermore, I could
divide by the population.
We'd have a bubble per capita.
And I'll do the same
trick I just did before,
with apologies,
but I'm not going
to go through the algebra.
Take the Lt, divide
through, then
you have a mismatch
between t plus 1 and t.
Then have Lt plus 1 divided
by Lt plus 1, parse it out,
and you get this thing, that
the real per capita bubble is
moving over time, according
to the marginal product
of capital.
But that arithmetic,
which over here
created the 1 plus n hanging out
there, that extra term, that 1
plus n is in this math as well.
And you're just dividing by it.
So that's where the
n is coming from,
that rate of population growth.
This is all a big
premise right now.
We're just saying, if there
were money, if it had value,
the value of it has to
be increasing at the rate
that they can earn money in
another way, namely by storing.
And so you're
getting an equation
for how the value of
the bubble, hence money,
must be evolving over time.
Now, savings can be done in the
two ways, as I've kept saying,
but here's the equation.
When they're young, we
have the savings function
of the young people,
depending on the wage
and tomorrow's interest rate,
times a number of young people.
But they can save in two ways.
They can save in the
real bubble or they
can save in the capital stock.
And now, again, doing
that same math as always,
start solving for Kt plus 1.
Subtract B off of
the right-hand side.
Then divide through by the
appropriate labor term,
and you get this expression.
That's the third time
we're doing the algebra.
It should kind of
be obvious where
it's coming from because Kt
plus 1 is equal to Ls minus B.
And the rest of it is
finding that end term
and dividing through
by that term.
So now, this is just
another way of saying
that the amount of
capital next period
is what it would have been
before in the real economy
without money, except now
we have bubbles of money
that have value.
So we've got to
subtract off the bubble.
That's kind of preventing
the capital stock from being
as large as it would have been.
So 3, this thing, gets rewritten
at the top of the next slide
to be the bubble b So now solve
this thing for b, little b,
bubble per capita.
It's this thing, and
that's one equation.
And we also know something
about bubbles over time.
As I was saying, we did that.
That was this
thing at the bottom
of the slide before last.
So we have those two equations.
This has to be true
in a steady state.
Should emphasize.
There are t's all over the place
here, but in a steady state,
we're not going to
have any evolution.
So the t's are
going to disappear.
So Kt plus 1 will equal Kt.
There'll be no t on the
b, Kt, blah, blah, blah.
So when I rewrote 3
hurriedly just then,
I rewrote it without the t's.
And that's what this
thing is at the top.
And with the t's, we have
this thing, the second term,
which I've just pasted
in from previously.
So if we're going to have a
steady state, then these b's
can't be moving around.
So bt plus 1 over bt has
got to be a constant.
And if the left-hand
side is the same,
1, then the right-hand
side has to be the same, 1.
Hence, the marginal
product of capital
has to be equal to the
rate of population growth.
So if there is a steady
state with a real bubble,
then the rate of
population growth
has to be equal to the
marginal product of capital,
this thing at the bottom here.
There's a couple of
other ways to see this.
One, take this equation, but let
me rewrite it verbally for you.
We have output coming from
the production function.
Take this k and put it
on the right-hand side.
You can always eat the capital.
You remember that
medieval village economy
with seed and storage
and all of that, where
we talked about the evolution?
So you can always eat this, the
harvest, or you can save it.
So it's like that.
So this k can be eaten.
So you have total
resources available today
to be f of k plus k.
And how do you use that stuff?
You can eat it or save it.
Eat it today, that's c.
Tomorrow, tomorrow's k,
would be k, except darn it.
We got that population
growth again.
So if we're going to keep k
constant in a steady state,
the resource requirements to
have a constant per capita
capital stock
tomorrow are that you
have to augment the capital
per capita today by n.
Same trick, fourth time.
So anyway, writing
it that way, we
want to maximize consumption.
So you solve consumption
equals to f of k plus k
minus k times then 1 plus n.
And where is that
object, that c maximized?
It's maximized by finding
the first-order condition,
and that's exactly where f
prime of k is equal to n.
So that's so-called golden rule.
Distressed to see this morning
that this k star is not,
however, the previous k star.
This is a new
golden rule k star.
Should have called the other
k autarky for the economy
without money.
In this case, star
would be the golden rule
k for the steady state
bubble equilibrium.
So it doesn't have
to happen that you
will be at the steady state.
If k were greater than k star,
everyone could be better off.
Why?
It's as if, if you started at
k greater than the golden rule,
the economy's
overaccumulated the capital.
And then to maintain a constant
per capita capital stock,
you've got to take
something out of production,
not eat it, and squirrel
it away for tomorrow.
You could actually do better
by increasing consumption
of the current generation,
having less capital
stock to maintain,
and then going out
to the infinite future.
None of the future generations
are going to be worse off.
This experiment is
exactly like what
we did last time with the
infinite number of goods
economy, where we can engineer
a one-time improvement
in at least one of the
agents by creating something
from nowhere.
Basically, we move the
overaccumulation of capital
into the current generation
and let them eat it.
And then, subsequent
generations don't suffer either
because they don't
have to try to maintain
this per capita capital
stock, which was too large.
So is it possible
that the economy
can overaccumulate capital?
Yes.
So we're going to look at two
steady states, the previous one
without any money
and the new one
with the steady state bubble.
An interesting thing about
the steady state bubble,
this one that we've
already described,
is that it has the property that
it achieves the golden rule.
And that's because-- you
can kind of see it here--
when the bubble is constant
and not depending on time,
then f prime of k
must be equal to n.
So the golden rule is
achieved in the steady state
of the bubble equilibrium.
And that was this top line.
In a steady state with bubbles,
the golden rule is achieved.
And that's going
to be this point.
So that's k star,
that's the golden rule
k, corresponds to a
particular bubble that
solves the other equation.
That's called a b star.
This is what we
would like to get to.
And what happens in the
economy with no money?
You're down here at
essentially an autarky value.
So this is a perfectly fine
competitive equilibrium.
There is no money.
But in it, the economy will
have overaccumulated capital.
And a Pareto improvement
can be engineered
by reducing the
amount of capital.
How does that happen
in a steady state?
You give other people a way
to save in worthless stuff.
So instead of real
physical savings,
they're scrambling to get
these pieces of paper.
The rate of return on
the pieces of the paper
has to be the same
as physical savings.
It has no intrinsic value.
It has an extrinsic value
because the price of money
is positive.
So in other words, these
perfectly worthless pieces
of paper, fiat
money, have a value
in a competitive equilibrium.
And the money's actually helping
to recover the Pareto optimum.
So you see the connection to
the welfare theorems here.
We have an infinite
number of people,
an infinite number of periods.
The welfare theorems fail.
If you start adding
up the value of wealth
in the autarky
equilibrium, it goes
to infinity like last time.
That's why the first
welfare theorem fails.
And the way to
recover optimality
is to create these
worthless pieces of paper
and let them trade.
It's totally amazing.
But it's an intrinsic
part of money.
However there's a downside
here, which is it's unstable.
So let me just describe
what's going on
without expecting you to be
able to reproduce all the math.
You're plotting, this
was the autarky value.
This is the golden rule
value that we want.
Now we want to look at
starting from different points
with the economy evolved to one
or the other of those points.
And this is an
equation, depending
on whether you're above it or
below it for the capital stock
to evolve, this equation, the
BB, bubble bubble equation,
has to do with whether you're
to the left or the right of it,
whether the bubble is evolving.
And these arrows
denote all the forces
in the underlying economy.
And if you're lucky and you
start away from the golden rule
steady state, you would
evolve on a knife edge
and eventually converge to it.
So this is the good news.
The economies that start with
an appropriate amount of bubble
or capital will evolve to
this optimal golden rule,
so steady state.
But this is the
really bad news--
this economy can also evolve
to real savings and no money.
And money inflates away.
It could start with
a positive value.
This is an equilibrium.
And it doesn't
require stupid people.
This is a fully rational
expectation dynamic path, where
the value of money goes to 0.
OK, well, so why
did I show you that?
I can replace the word fiat
money with cryptocurrency
and ask what value
it ought to have.
It's perfectly plausible
to me that you could
see the price moving around.
Maybe it will go to
some constant value
if this Bitcoin is also
useful in exchange,
the way money is in that
overlapping generation's model.
Maybe it's going to it's
going to collapse again,
and the price will go to 0.
All those phenomenon
are perfectly
consistent with Bitcoin playing
a useful role in exchange
but not able to
find a stable value.
But again, the point
is, and actually we've
been emphasizing this,
starting with fiat money
the way Samuelson did, it's
a property of any money.
It's a property of
fiat money and so on.
The Fed worries a lot
about forward guidance.
They're constantly
telling people
what they predict to
happen in the future
so people don't panic.
If you think fiat
money is not going
to be worth what it
is in the future,
you're not going
to want to hold it.
Oh, that's one
explanation that traders
have for what's going
on with Bitcoin, namely,
there's just an
ever-increasing amount
of government debt
in the economy.
The Fed has bought up all
those securities effectively
and issued accounts
at the Federal Reserve
in worthless pieces of paper.
Are you scared now?
So the market may
be anticipating
that, in fact, there aren't
enough real resources
to pay off the debt.
The only way that
the Fed and European
governments are going to pay
off the debt is to inflate.
And if the market starts
to expect inflation,
fiat money is less valued, and
they're shifting into Bitcoin.
So that's what traders
think is going on.
I switched the
story on you a bit
because now we have
fiat money competing
with Bitcoin and vice versa.
But I think you
could imagine how you
could get both in the model.
So the way you get
both in the model
is to set up an underlying
economic environment
and have gaps.
Say autarky households
aren't smoothing,
there's a lot of fluctuations,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
fiat money can help smooth.
But maybe fiat money doesn't
smooth it out entirely.
And then, you're left
for tokens like Bitcoin
to play a role on
top of fiat money.
So you could actually
have both in the model.
It's not true that one
has to dominate the other.
They could both coexist.
And partly what we're seeing
in these cryptosystems
is crypto coins are a way of
transferring fiat money around.
You just create tokens that
get transferred around.
But they're claims on the
underlying fiat money.
But the tokens can
have value because they
facilitate exchange,
even if they're not
backed by the fiat money.
So we could get both of them in.
Now, this is pretty abstract,
this overlapping generations
model.
You might say it's
totally unrealistic.
By the way, it's
another interpretation
of Social Security
with pay as you go,
namely the young pay
in to Social Security,
but it's not sitting there
in some fund or something.
It's not in a lockbox.
It's just flowing right
out to the old generation.
So people have criticized
Samuelson's model
as a not realistic
model of money
because of the
extreme assumptions
about finite two-period
lives and so on.
But could it be applied?
Well, these guys, Abel, Mankiw,
Summers, and Zeckhauser said,
look, we could
actually look to see
whether economies are on an
efficient or inefficient path.
And I thought I had started
this on the reading list.
So anyway, you can read this.
Yeah, yeah, I did.
It's on the reading list.
You should be able
to understand it.
This, you won't understand.
It's just explaining
what they did.
They didn't find
any inefficiency,
but a subsequent
person, Geerolf, did.
He adjusted what those guys
did to take out land rent,
having profits of
entrepreneurs divvied up
into opportunity cost wages.
And he actually finds that
Korea, Taiwan, Singapore,
those East Asian
growth economies,
with all that capital, they
were actually inefficient.
They were accumulating
too much capital.
They were beyond
the golden rule.
It's really fascinating.
All right.
The other part is what I was
alluding to at the beginning.
If you create more and
more real financial claims
that can be traded, then fiat
money can also be vulnerable.
And you could convert
those economies with money
to economies without them.
So when you have Bitcoin and
tokens and cryptocurrencies
and especially
digital assets, which
are claims on real
capital circulating
in the economy as money, you
may end up with that model
where there is no
valued fiat money.
And again, that would
threaten central banks.
But it doesn't mean
it's a bad thing.
In our terminology,
it could be going
toward a new
Pareto-optimal allocation.
Other ways to get
money in the model,
you could require
it to pay taxes.
So even if there's
a last period,
everyone has to pay
it in, otherwise
it could have 0 value.
So the very first
monetary models
were finite-period models,
but in the last period,
people have to pay
taxes in money.
Some governor in Ohio
got a smart idea which,
is I guess he liked technology.
He is allowing Ohio citizens
to pay their state income
taxes in Bitcoin.
Maybe that'll
stabilize the price.
And you could require that
money be used for goods.
We have not been writing
models like that.
This is like fiat.
Literally, by law, you're
required to use money.
And you have to hold it and
have to have acquired it
earlier in some way.
These are called cash
in advance models.
So if you have certain types
of goods in the economy that
require cash, and
those are valued goods
with a margin utility
of infinite at 0,
then the value of
cash isn't going
to fall to 0 because
if it were, you'd never
be able to buy those goods.
So that's kind of
a way of, again,
a mechanical way of making
sure the value of money
doesn't go to 0.
Like it or not, I'm exposing
you to different modeling
strategies.
So let me come back to
the starting point, which
are these agents that
go 0, 1, 0 and 1, 0, 1.
This is a spatial
model of money.
Why is the money going
to be valued here?
Because they're not all
together to trade with one
another at some initial date
over all these future paths
of consumption.
They can only trade with
each other when they meet.
So this is an extreme version
of incomplete markets.
And you know what can happen
to competitive equilibria
with incomplete markets.
They don't have to be optimal.
Specifically, let's write down
the problem of an agent of type
of I. If you can see this.
It's a little bit tiny.
We have discounted
utility of consumption.
Consumption and money
are non-negative.
And we have this
budget equation,
which reads like this--
they have some endowment,
maybe positive.
This is now the dollar
price, by the way,
of goods, the usual price.
They have the valuation
of their endowment
plus the money they brought
in from the previous period.
They may have to pay
some lump-sum taxes.
But then the residual can be
used either to buy consumption
or to take money over
to the next state.
So again, this is
like sources and uses.
And what's the solution to this?
Solution, by the way, by
manipulating the money.
The way they determine how much
they're eating today or eating
tomorrow is to either
cash out the money
or acquire it and store
it and carry it over.
So not too surprisingly, you
might expect, and it's true,
that the marginal-- let
me write it down here--
that with one exception, the
marginal rate of substitution
in consumption, of consumption
at t minus 1 for consumption
at t, that ought to
equal the price ratio.
So remember your basic lectures,
consumer theory, two periods,
money is a way to
carry value over
from one period to the next.
It's like borrowing and
lending, except that it
appreciates or depreciates
depending on the price level.
So you would expect
this equality to hold,
that the tangency involves the
marginal rate of substitution
and consumption on
the indifference
curve equal to the price ratio
implicit in the budget model.
Now, I was covering
up the inequality
because it could be that
you're holding money.
The marginal utility
of consumption
today is greater than the
marginal utility tomorrow
discounted.
So you'd like to eat more today.
So you start driving that money
down, and the money hits 0,
and you can't go negative.
And still, the
margin utility today
is greater than the
margin utility tomorrow.
So these guys actually--
where did it go?
These guys here
experienced that.
They start at 1.
They acquire money.
They're going to
have 0 next period.
They start dumping the
money, but they run out,
and they can't go negative.
So for them,
they're at a corner.
Guys that come in with
money and spend it,
because otherwise they
have no endowment at all,
are nevertheless not going
to have enough money.
So we can look
for an equilibrium
where for some periods
and some types of agents,
this is at a strict
inequality, namely
the guys that are hitting 0.
And the other ones 0 endowment.
And the other ones,
it is that equality.
Let me draw you the picture.
So even though it's an
infinite horizon economy,
we can reduce it to
a two-period economy
and guess what the steady
state equilibrium is
going to look like.
Guys that start with
1 unit would be here.
If they just ate
their endowment,
they would have consumption
of 1 today and none tomorrow.
And then, moving
along the budget line,
at constant prices,
they get money today,
giving up consumption good
today, and get money tomorrow.
If the price level
of money tomorrow,
price of goods tomorrow is
the price of goods today,
then they're moving right
along this budget line.
And where would they end up?
Well, here's an
indifference curve.
Here's a tangency.
It's on the budget line.
Now, how did I know
it would be there?
Namely, look at this expression.
This is the marginal
utility at t minus 1 to t
or the marginal utility
at t to t plus 1.
There's a beta down here.
Tomorrow doesn't count so much.
Beta is between 0 and 1.
So the utility, margin
utility tomorrow,
is always less than the
margin utility today.
The only thing that
could compensate for it
is the price movement.
But if we start with
constant prices,
then this expression
is only going
to hold if we're able
to adjust consumption.
We want to get the
margin utility up.
Consumption at t is
greater than at t plus 1
in order to get the margin
utility up to the point
that the marginal
rate of substitution
is equal to the
constant price ratio.
Now, is this a good
thing or a bad thing?
Well, it is going to be
a monetary equilibrium.
The guess is good.
So the path would
be guys with 1 are
going to go to c star and then
c double star, then c star, then
c double star, with money
moving in the opposite direction
from something positive, when
they have 1 they acquire it,
to 0, hitting the corner,
back to positive amount again.
So money is going to
alternate over time
at the individual level.
Consumption is going
to alternate over time.
The money is going to have
value at a constant price.
But unlike the overlapping
generations model,
this one is not a
Pareto-optimal allocation,
even though we have money.
You actually know
the answer already.
Let me remind you.
How do we determine
a Pareto optimum?
Well, let's all the guys
that start with, say, 0
be called A types,
and all the guys
that start with 1 unit
of the consumption
are going to be called B types.
And then, maximize the
weighted sums of utility.
We usually have lambdas here.
I apologize.
Now, they're w's.
This is the weight on type A.
wB is the weight on type B.
We maximize the weighted
sums of expected--
there's nothing random--
discounted utility
for both of them.
We get a first-order condition.
You remember this stuff?
We've done this before.
This is the Pareto problem.
Weighted margin utilities are
going to be equated over agents
and equal to a constant
Lagrange multiplier.
You've seen this before.
This is a new
application, that's all.
So the marginal rate,
solving this equation,
the marginal rates of
substitution over the agents
have to be the same.
But does it pin
down the allocation?
No.
We're in an Edgeworth box.
There's one good in the
aggregate available today,
one good in the aggregate
available tomorrow.
We know the Pareto
optimum has to give
all the guys equal consumption.
You can satisfy this
by having type A having
constant consumption, type B
having constant consumption,
but those consumptions don't
have to be equal to each other
because things are
going to cancel out
of the numerator
or the denominator.
So this picture, marginal
rate of substitution
for day t and day tau is
equal to each other for agents
type A and type B.
But to review, right,
you remember this lecture
when we did the Pareto
optimum and your Edgeworth box?
You can be anywhere
on the contract curve,
and it's all Pareto optimal.
Anything that's off the
diagonal is not Pareto optimal
in this environment.
And this one is
off the diagonal.
So it's not Pareto optimal.
Where do you want to go?
You kind of want to go here.
And how would you engineer that?
You have to generate
a deflation so
that they're getting a positive
real rate of return on money.
That's going to make them
want to hold more money
and eat less today.
And that's going to
put them at a tangency
up here where they
have equal consumption.
So there is a
Pareto-optimal allocation.
It's a monetary
equilibrium, but it's
an equilibrium with an
activist monetary policy that's
withdrawing enough currency out
of the system in lump-sum taxes
to create a deflation.
Deflation isn't bad here.
It means that the purchasing
power of money is going up.
So that's all the rest of these
slides I don't have time for.
You are able to achieve these
Pareto optimal allocations
but only with an activist
monetary policy, which
is deliberately manipulating
the amount of currency
in the system.
Questions.
So welcome to the land
of monetary economics.
It's a lot of fun.
So now you're able to
see in this last lecture
how real financial
markets are linked
to money markets, the role of
cryptocurrency, controversies
involving its price, and how
we as economists can think
about these values, and
actually how we would
recommend monetary policy.
And I will add that if
there was cryptocurrency,
you would want an activist
amount of manipulation
of the amount of
cryptocurrency in the system
for the same reason that
I just described to you.